well for a lot of calendar year 2018 the
creepy porn lawyer was a bona fide star
on cable news CNN had him on so often he
brought a covered dish to the company
picnic over an MSNBC familiarity bred
enchantment they were starting to
worship the guy he's a beast he's a
beast that he keeps the popping Donald
Trump in all of his folks in the mouth
Jon Meacham says he may be the savior of
the Republic Oh Michael avenatti an
apology for the last couple of weeks
I've been saying I'm not for reading
Michael I've seen you everywhere what do
you have love to say I was wrong brother
since your question how dumb would you
have to be to find the creepy porn
lawyer impressive he was such a
transparent fraud such a total con in it
only for himself there was no question
about that
ever we told him so directly the night
he came to visit us on the show watch
you've profited from stormy Daniels
you've done tens of millions of dollars
with the free media on the basis of your
relationship with her and she's working
in strip clubs you're exploiting her and
you know that why aren't you paying her
some of what you're making sir this is
absurd but answer my question why are
you rich and your client is working in
seedy strip clubs sir do you have any
idea how much money ever you're on every
cable show you're running for president
no idea I know that you haven't paid
your taxes like so many lawyers you were
taking advantage of her and you pose as
a feminist hero because you are
shameless and the other channels let you
get away with it but you're an exploiter
of a woman and you should be ashamed of
it
we hate to brag almost never do but
tonight we're gonna make a rare
exception we were right about him today
the creepy porn lawyer was indicted on a
new set of criminal charges they allege
that he defrauded yes stormy Daniels
turns out he was not a feminist hero
according to the indictments EPL forged
her signature on a letter and then used
it to steal her book advance he blew
that on hotels restaurants and things
like that
all the while stormy Daniels worked in
strip clubs to pay her bills the creepy
porn lawyer live luxuriously on her
misfortune is anyone outside of cable
news surprised by this
what's the Francisco hos outnumbered on
this network
a friend of ours and she joins us
tonight Lissa I know you were not
surprised by this but like the whole
primetime lineup on a bunch of other
channels must have their jaws open they
wanted you to be President
yeah they were very excited about him
and you ran through the details very
well especially looking back at that
interview and what you said in him
saying oh no I wasn't explaining her it
turns out right that he was forging her
name to divert funds that were coming to
her for her book deal and putting them
in his account and he says in his
defense he was tweeting today basically
I was owed that because I was his lawyer
and then you say well then why did you
have to forge her name and then why then
did you tell her according to the
criminal indictment from the Southern
District why did you tell her that the
publisher refused to pay he's lying to
her he's lying to everyone to divert the
money but his defenses I was owed it and
that's just one of the small things I
mean when you look through the whole
thing with Nike he extorted Nike he
waited til earnings period this is all
alleged and according to what the
southern district is saying the feds are
saying but they claim that he waited
until Nikes earnings period when they
would be most vulnerable and then he
said you have done wrong and I am going
to have a press conference if you don't
hire me right now to audit your company
for twenty million dollars and I'll be
your internal counsel to audit your
company and see but or the caveat was
you can just give me twenty two million
and I'll be quiet and go away now these
this is all in the paperwork that came
out today that we read and he's tweeting
back in his defense I will be exonerated
I was owed this money in all of these
different cases all told he could go to
jail for four hundred and four years and
in my book it's really not enough for
everything that he did I mean he also
had bank fraud wire fraud he filed for
bankruptcy he lied and that proceeding
all alleged again alleged but this is a
lot of piling on in California in New
York all over the place and it kind of
hits on two themes that our viewers love
here number one is hypocrisy and that's
what you really put out there when you
had that interview with him where he's
standing there holier than thou filled
with sanctum Oh
he's saying this person broke the law
this person is immoral I was standing up
for what's right and the law and this
and that in here
he according to these officials and
these law enforcement officers he's one
of the biggest criminals and predators
out there according to what they're
saying the other thing that I think is
really interesting that that your
viewers love is the irony because you've
got to think that he was doing this for
a long time I mean there are many
clients he's accused of defrauding and
he spent the money on Ferraris they say
and on a private plane they say so he
was living the lifestyle and defrauding
people who were being paid for
legitimate things but he didn't get
caught until he went all over television
till he was dropped on his own Fame and
he had people like Stephanie ruhle over
there at MSNBC celebrating him right I
mean until he had people where's their
judgment it was so it was away with it
obvious look I actually feel sorry for
him at this stage I mean there's clearly
something wrong with him I don't know I
don't want to speculate but there's
clearly something wrong there always has
been something wrong with the guy and
any person who spent two minutes of them
would know that and yet somehow they
didn't know that these purveyors of
facts well you know because they were
doing the work that they wanted done he
was out there doing the work she knows
happen with someone to go after Brett
Kavanaugh I mean he always had exactly
Daniels to go after the president I mean
he was he was doing the bidding of what
the other networks wanted I guess so
they looked past in the work of the
Democratic Party I just think it's
interesting that had he not gotten drunk
on his own fame he might have gotten
away with it it's almost like a
scooby-doo episode for you kids kids
right and your dog right well let's
Francisco great to see you